25 de mayo de 1983 Argentina iniciaba
una era política hoy 20 años después el
kirchnerismo celebra su llegada al poder
aquella facción del peronismo que hizo
su Debut con la presidencia de Néstor
kirchner en 2003 seguido por su esposa
Cristina Fernández que gobernó hasta
2015 y actualmente es la vicepresidenta
de la nación pero el aniversario llega
en medio de una ruptura entre el
gobierno Cristina Fernández será la
única oradora en el evento que se espera
sea multitudinario y al que no está
invitado el presidente Alberto Fernández
en este año 2023 se cumplen 40 años de
democracia ininterrumpida en nuestro
país sin embargo una parte importante de
la ciudadanía no se siente representada
ni contenida sus aspiraciones en una
democracia que se perdió en lo económico
degradó en lo social y ha comenzado a
romperse en lo político e institucional
una jornada festival Argentina que
conmemora el día de la patria y en el
cual se espera conocer el nombre del
candidato del kirchnerismo en las
elecciones presidenciales de octubre ya
que la ex mandataria no puede participar
los kirchner promovieron la
reivindicación de los derechos de las
víctimas de la dictadura militar pero la
reputación de su movimiento se ve
afectada por una inflación que en abril
llegó al 108.8% anual según datos
oficiales lo que compramos a la mañana
con esta inflación a la tarde compramos
la mitad es una situación muy crítica
entonces este gobierno no toma nota en
las elecciones de octubre se medirá la
fuerza del kirchnerismo y el impacto de
la condena en contra de Cristina
Fernández a seis años de prisión e
inhabilitación política por corrupción
cuando era presidenta